man to my right malcolm-jamal Warner on
10 days in the valley good to see you
good to see you this is awesome having
you sitting here in studio how so we
were chatting backstage you're from
Jersey City correct yes I was Jersey
born in Jersey City okay yeah and then
my parents split up moved to California
and I was five yeah they wanna book
Cosby around thirteen we moved back to
New York to shoot that show now did you
did you test for Cosby shows that well
yeah you get like a test in the left
boom audition yeah but it's funny I was
literally the lot the last person they
saw my agent had submitted me early on
when they were casting right but they
were looking for a six one 15 year old
and I was like five five and thirteen so
hey they had and and you know PI the
running joke cuz you know mr. Cosby's
son Ennis was six one at 15 right so
Dina there was one of the I saw one of
the original scripts there's you know
deals getting in trouble didn't close
like you know Theo stand up and he
stands up and he's an inch taller than
the cliffs this Theo sit down yes
that's kind of one of the running jokes
but they couldn't cast that guy and I
was literally the last person they saw
and then just boom you were hired yeah
what was that experience like for you
Malcolm I mean just like you're a kid
and then all of a sudden you were on one
of the monster hit television shows in
the history of the medium yeah it was
awesome to be honest yeah it was I mean
growing up in New York I think helped a
great deal
hmm because you know it was obviously a
phenomenally successful show but we were
living in New York and not LA and you
know have we been in LA there were
Venice a whole different experience in
terms right and always being on a
soundstage you know your best friends
being on you know a couple of stages
down the street and you know down down
the way on the same lot sure so this
allowed us you know we shot in Brooklyn
and there was no commissary in our
particular studio so at lunchtime we had
to walk the neighborhood to get our food
so there was just a different experience
being in New York yeah then if we had
done that show no I thought you were
said you just went to mr. Hooper's place
on Sesame
probably shooting it right around the
block actually no I did I did finally
make it to mr. Hooper's place usually
for yeah you just went there and you
bought something out there you know we
know actually I had directed a couple
episodes of obsessive come on yeah bad
yeah so that was that was what do you
mean you what do you mean you directed
it I do it well you know I started out
even I started out directing like early
on on Cosmo so I was actually directing
Cosby while we were on how old are you
18
you're an 18 year old director yeah at
the time I was the youngest director
India and the DGA Daniel yeah and then a
year later Kirk Cameron got in the DA
okay so you beat you yeah yeah but I
started directing early on it's doing
like in my own just got my own little
video shoots because I knew directing
was one of the things that I wanted to
do to stay consistently active short
business Malcolm Jamal Warner here on
the Rich Eisen show I imagine like Ahmad
Rashad was around the set yeah did you
know that he was gonna propose on that
football game
no no that's down on the knee and yeah
that was a total surprise yeah everybody
yeah everybody everyone's talking about
it was like a huge thing in the sports
world at the time at a mod Rashad got
down on a knee and then BOOM the
pressure I remember he was sweating too
and he was trying to sweat and and hit
some Kleenex state in his beer right he
was a nervous wreck so are you a New
York do you have New York sports roots
or Los Angeles sports roots what did you
order your sports routes what in LA in
there grew up on the Lakers okay I'm so
that was like time the Lakers had really
been my thing when I was when I was six
mm-hmm I proclaimed to my parents that I
was either going to be a famous actor a
famous poet or famous basketball player
because I had in my head I was gonna
play for the Lakers yeah and you know I
mmm
best ball games not that great yeah you
just realized early on yeah I look great
playing but when I actually got the ball
it was a whole nother story so you
couldn't go to your left couldn't go to
your ride no so let you went to this
harp
[Laughter]
yes this Chris and so I guess was at the
back end of the magic Johnson days it
was voiceover it was it was early early
Magic Johnson days I had a um so my
mom's boss at the time had season
tickets to the game so he would always
give him to her and I would go to the
forum you know we'd be like you know
four or five rolls from the court hmm
and then at the end of the game I would
be the kid at the players entrance
trying to get autographs who'd you get I
got I've got this huge scrapbook and I
mean Kurt Rambis Michael Cooper Byron
Scott yeah
Jamal Wilks Jamal will Jimmy what a
great shot here well smooth he was
smooth yeah yeah and I got I got magic
and I got Kareem this is after creme is
stop signing autographs because you know
he [ __ ] kids were not they weren't
they weren't grateful they weren't
appreciative and we were there the night
he scored his 1,000th NBA point and at
the after the game I was at the players
interest getting autographs and Kareem
came out and I was like mr. Carrillo
Jabbar can have your autograph please
and he signed my my little little pad
and I was like thank you thank you thank
you I was so happy because I knew he
didn't sign autographs anymore so I
asked just for the hell of it and he
signed it for me and I went home and I
showed it to my mom and my mom said to
me baby one day Kareem is gonna know who
you are
and I was like you know 11 12 years old
and my mom is saying like y'all mom yes
mom saying yeah and yeah and I was about
six or seven years ago
I was able to tell him that story what'd
he say he left oh good four days ago
yeah yeah he looks great man yeah he my
dad my dad was reactive in in the civil
rights movement he named me after
Malcolm X and the MA Jamal so in any
sports figure who you know who really
was about social consciousness my
had me reading about so I was so I've
been following I knew creams like I knew
him from Lewis indoor days I knew you
know his whole story playing at power so
being able to meet him as a kid was
really a huge thing for me and then as
an adult it had even a more profound
impact on me when I just realized how
much I'd been studying this man as a kid
Malcolm Jamal Warner here on the Rich
Eisen show so this new show attend days
in the valley I had no idea there would
ever make a TV show based on how long it
takes me and my wife to take my kids to
school but but it's not actually about
that it's something completely different
you and kyra sedgwick are in this show
at Erika Christensen who was a
phenomenal actress as well what does
this show about for those who were keen
to tune in on story well Akira and I
were exec producers of this show within
the show this cop show and Kira's
character gets a lot of information she
has consulted and she's getting you know
all the the skinny on the police
corruption and she uses those stories in
this cop show that we're producing
suddenly her daughter goes missing and
now Kara's character needs the help of
the cops to find her daughter but
they're not really unfriendly turns
because she's exposing all of their
corruption and it's intrigue it is make
or every every character on this show
turns out to be a suspect like
everyone's got secrets
everyone's got you know a dark side that
they're hiding and just as a viewer it's
pretty engaging like I saw the first
eight episodes and you know even knowing
the script knowing the story I was still
very intriguing and then interest and
then again that's uh that's ten days in
the valley premiering this Sunday 10:00
Eastern on ABC and Sunday is when just
two because again you played al cowlings
in the FX series OJ's getting out yeah
on Sunday and on Monday did you meet did
you ever meet al did you know
how did you research for the for that
role that I had I gleaned all the
information I could off the internet men
you know really the approach I took was
you know friendship and you know knowing
how much OJ meant ow you know all across
the board
I mean his you know the friendship the
lifestyle and kind of you know the kind
of relationship of you're always the man
sitting next to the man a year the man
who's in you know your partner shadow
but it affords you a certain lifestyle
that's that's tough to give up yeah I
know I mean that that was a fascinating
series you were great in that look
forward to ten days in the valley
tonight on Sunday 10:00 Eastern Time
come back anytime look you got a
malcolm-jamal Warner here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
that video be sure to download our app
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slow-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about